Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Neural network-based learning methods are
capable of wondrous things these days.
They can do classification, which means that
they look at an image, and the output is a
decision, whether we see a dog or a cat, or
a sentence that describes an image.
In the case of DeepMind’s AI playing Atari
games, the input is the video footage of the
game, and the output is an action that decides
what we do with our character next.
In OpenAI’s amazing Jukebox paper, the input
was a style of someone, a music genre, and
lyrics, and the output was a waveform, or
in other words, a song we can listen to.
But, a few hundred episodes ago we covered
a paper from 2015, where scientists at DeepMind
asked the question, what if we would get these
neural networks to output not sentences, decisions,
waveforms or any of that sort… what if the
output would be a computer program?
Can we teach a neural network programming?
I was convinced that the answer is no, until
I saw these results.
So what is happening here?
The input is a scratch pad where we are performing
multi-digit addition in front of the curious
eyes of the neural network.
And if it has looked for long enough, it was
indeed able to produce a computer program
that could, eventually, perform addition.
It could also perform sorting, and would even
be able to rotate the images of these cars
into a target position.
It was called a neural programmer-interpreter,
and of course, it was slow and a bit inefficient,
but no matter, because it could finally make
something previously impossible possible.
That is an amazing leap.
So, why are we talking about this work from
2015?
Well, apart from the fact that there are many
amazing works that are timeless, and this
is one of them, in this series, I always say,
two more papers down the line, and it will
be improved significantly.
So here is the Two Minute Papers Moment of
Truth.
How has this area improved with this followup
work?
Let’s have a look at this paper from scientists
at NVIDIA that implements a similar concept
for computer games.
So how is that even possible?
Normally, if we wish to write a computer game,
we first, envision the game in our mind, then,
we sit down and do the programming.
But this new paper does this completely differently.
Now, hold on to your papers, because this
is a neural network-based method, that first,
looks at someone playing the game, and then,
it is able to implement the game so that it
not only looks like it, but it also behaves
the same way to our keypresses.
You see it at work here.
Yes, this means that we can even play with
it and it learns the internal rules of the
game and the graphics, just by looking at
some gameplay.
Note that the key part here is that we are
not doing any programming by hand - the entirety
of the program is written by the AI.
We don’t need access to the source code
or the internal workings of the game, as long
as we can just look at it, it can learn the
rules.
Everything truly behaves as expected, we can
even pick up the capsule and eat the ghosts
as well.
This sounds like science fiction, and we are
not nearly done yet!
There are additional goodies.
It has memory and uses it consistently, or,
in other words, things don’t just happen
arbitrarily.
If we return to a state of the game that we
visited before, it will remember to present
us with very similar information.
It also has an understanding of foreground
and background, dynamic and static objects
as well, so we can experiment with replacing
these parts, thereby reskinning our games.
It still needs quite a bit of data to perform
all this as it has looked at approximately
120 hours of footage of the game being played,
however, now, something is possible that was
previously impossible.
And of course, two more papers down the line,
this will be improved significantly I am sure.
I think this work is going to be one of those
important milestones that remind us that many
of the things that we had handcrafted methods
for will, over time, be replaced with these
learning algorithms.
They already know the physics of fluids, or
in other words, they are already capable of
looking at videos of these simulations and
learn the underlying physical laws, and they
can demonstrate having learned general knowledge
of the rules by being able to continue these
simulations, even if we change the scene around
quite a bit.
In light transport research, we also have
decades of progress in simulating how rays
of light interact with scenes and we can create
these beautiful images.
Parts of these algorithms, for instance, noise
filtering are already taken over by AI-based
techniques, and I can’t help but feel that
a bigger tidal wave is coming.
This tidal-wave will be an entirely AI-driven
technique that will write the code for the
entirety of the system.
Sure the first ones will be limited, for instance,
this is a neural renderer from one of our
papers that is limited to this scene and lighting
setup, but you know the saying, two more papers
down the line, and it will be an order of
magnitude better.
I can’t wait to tell all about it to you
with a video when this happens.
Make sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon
to not miss any followup works.
Goodness, I love my job.
What a time to
be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!